I definitely would not want to fall from
this height
we need to get the hive out of the
branches and lower it down
we're gonna bring it down we're going to
lower it this thing's heavy yeah I have
it
bees release pheromones when they're
threatened so Joseph uses smoke to
disrupt their sense of smell and stop
them from swarming
the bees are acting up but the smoke is
doing its job
okay we have everything locked off up
here the hive is almost to the ground
suspended
we've got the hive down but we're not
going in for the honey just yet
the okiek know that the bees are
reluctant to fly at night and are far
more docile
so for now we must wait for the light to
fade
now is the time it's plenty dark enough
now it's not getting any darker than
this so by Fire Light they're gonna dig
right into that hive
they're really buzzing around in there
kind of bees these are East African
honeybees
The Hive like this can have 40 000 bees
being stung and numbers can be fatal
swarm the wrist is very real there's a
trap door on the bottom of this Hive
they're blowing more smoke in there
part of the hive with the honey
there it is that's it right there
that's what we're talking about
all the bees are angry now they're
starting to fly out
right in the armpit that's a bad one
smoke is preventing a swarm but some
bees are still going in for the attack
when they crawl on you they just sting
whatever feels like skin
I got one under my shirt
and I've already been stung about I
don't know six or seven times I don't
know these guys are getting stung too
they're working fast
trying to get the honeycomb
whoa
oh my gosh heavy with honey and then
those white Parts those are little baby
honeybees which isn't honey but it is
protein
might seem like a lot of work
to get honey but think about it there is
nothing out here sweeter than honey
[Music]
thank you